hello everyone I know that usually I'm
showing you some attacking games you
know wood fence sacrifices and
everything but for today I decided to
show you one of my favorite games by
Tigran Petrosian and although his ideas
are defensive in this game you'll see
how they could be turned into at
attacking ideas so this game petrosyan
is playing with the white pieces and was
dongjun occurs playing with the black
pieces and the unica is a wizard was a
very stronger German Grandmaster he was
considered to be the strongest German
Grandmaster told the 1970s and he won a
couple of areas from tournaments he when
shared first place with Boris Spassky in
the children memorial and well Anatoly
Karpov often says that uniquor is the
world champion amateurs because while he
chose law to be his professional chess
so that being said I just want to say
that being in the grip of the iron tiger
is a very dangerous and unpleasant so
make sure you watch this game from from
a safe distance so exposing is white and
única is black
Petrosyan plays d4 we have Knight to f6
Knight to f3 c6 Bishop to g5 d5 and now
from a very set of moves we reach a
position that could be called the Queens
gambit declined expertise in place c4 so
we have c6
Queen to c2 Bishop d7
III black castles night of c3 h6 Bishop
f4 and I'd be 37c capture some b5
tickets for 75 Bishop to d3 simply
developing we have a six the trojan
castles b5 expanding and the Queen said
I'm preparing to develop the light
square Bishop we have a four and this is
already the first move I want you to
really look at when patrols in place a
four he plays it with a with a defensive
idea
so eunuch replace B 4 and our Petrosyan
goes nice to a2 we have nice the e8 and
the Trojan plays nice to see one so we
have a five locking that b4 pawn
now propose in place a nice to be three
and I want you to look at this here so
we have this night here and the pawn on
a four and petrosyan has created some
kind of a castle here so this is pretty
much an impenetrable which is very
interesting because petrosian's King is
on the Kings side but you'll see what I
mean by this
so we have Bishop to a6 Petrosyan
captures the bishop an a6 rook captures
an a6 and now Queen to d3 with temple on
the rook we have worked to a7 and rook F
2 c1
so Petrosyan is controlling the C file
now we have a Knight to d6 and this nice
is preparing to jump to C for which
petrosyan will not allow so he captures
the knight Bishop captures and d6 Bishop
captures and d6 and now Petrosyan plays
a route to c6 attacking this bishop so
we have night to b8 attacking the rook
and protecting the bishop with the Queen
Petrosyan retreats the rook to see one
we have nice the d7 and of the Trojan a
place of rook a to see one and now he
has complete control of this C file
uniquor plays Knight to b6 we have Queen
to b5 Knight to c4 and this Knight is
now controlling this file since the
ropes can't go over tonight so Petrosyan
of course once they change it in ID to
uniquely captures Petrosyan captures and
queen to a eight and petrosyan puts the
rug back on the C file to regain his
control so we have worked to d8 and now
rook to c6
black plays g6 and in this position I
want you to really look at the position
like I said Petrosyan created this
castle here on the Queen side and by
putting the rook on c6
he is making sure that nothing can ever
attack this a four point because black
doesn't have a light square bishop so
during the way to attack this a four
point is well with the Queen and the
rook c6 will not allow that and what
does the frozen won't here Petrosyan
wants to attack on the King side which
is a bit dangerous because his King is
also on the Queen King side so petroleum
finds it amazing and the idea and this
is why this is one of my favorite games
played
by the iron tiger so the frozen place g3
this nullifies this bishops influence
and is diagonal completely so we have
Kings the g7 buy-in occur you know
improving the position of the black King
and now the frozen place I wonderful
move King to f1 and I'm sure this was
quite baffling to you Nakuru and it's
really hard to see what does the
president want with this King to f1 move
so uniquor just like link to that face
he thought okay petrosyan wants a draw
this is just you know a silly move so
petrosyan plays h4 and we have h v and
you can see the players have created
this very nice bone formation here with
the kings opposing each other from the
end of the board
but now pros employees rook to c2 and
this is also not - without a meaning but
again uniquor probably thinks okay he's
just you know making silly moves so he
plays King back to g7 and here petrosyan
played King Stewie 1 and I think in this
position that uniquor finally realized
what Petrosyan was doing but there is
nothing he can do to stop it so we have
King to g8 King steady 1 by petroleum we
have King at age 7 and now Petrosyan
plays kink the c1 so clink the g8 and
now Petrosyan plays King to be won and
if you remember I told you to really
remember to position and move 29 so if
you look at the position I'll move 29
this is the position before can get one
so Petrosyan king is here and the
tourism said that world he would like to
attack on the King side but it's a
problem because his king is in g1 so
this is the position six moves later and
if you look at this position it seems
that this the Trojans king teleported
from g1 to be won and well it seems that
his problems are solved you can now
attack on the Kings side so we have King
287 and now the chosen plays Queen to d2
preparing to attack on the Kings side so
we have Queen to be 7 and now rook the
c1 putting the rook back to the first
rank so he can serve the rook and join
the attack
we have Kings to g7 black doesn't really
have any moves this is like a complete
song with all the be almost all the
pieces on the board we have Queen to be
five Petrosyan most exchanged Queens
here twin occur if she refuses this
because it will be impossible to defend
this pawn so we have F 4 by Petrosyan
King to h7 and out twin deck te 2
preparing to push G 4 so we have Queen
to be 7 and now petrosyan pushes g4 we
have h captors on g4 twin casters in g4
and 27 so petrosyan goes h5 and we have
in to f6 by única a unike would like to
play Queen to at 5 and exchange Queens
and also this is defending the pawn on
g7 and in this position well Petrosian
isn't really interested in exchanging
Queens so Petrosyan says well I already
marched making from G want to be one I
might as well put it on a 2 and so he
does and it's interesting 57 years after
this well this this move is extremely
interesting and being commented in
YouTube so communica plays King to g7
and the frozen captures H peppers on g6
so we have Queen captures on g6 and now
Petrosyan plays Queen to h4 with the
tempo under broken d8 so we have Bishop
to e7 attacking the Queen and now the
Trojan again moves his queen with tempo
into f2 and this is threatening rock to
g1 and capturing the Queen so we have
Kings to f8 and now patrols in place
Knights to d2 she wants to play in 92
Knight to f3 and Knight to d5 so eunuch
your place rook to b7 but this gives the
Trojan another idea so he retreats the
nice to be three with a temple on the
pawn on f5 we have ripped a7 repeating
and now petroleum plays this Queen to h2
move and is preparing some nasty ideas
with Ruby G 1 and Queen h8 so we have
Bishop to f6 making room for the Kings
and also protecting h8 we have worked
the c8 and really now this is completely
controlled by Petrosyan
rook to d7
and now Petrosyan plays Knight to c5 and
although this seems like this is given
up a rope if the rook is captured
well then simply Knight captures on c7
which check will pick up this rook and
this game over so after an IC 5 eunuch
of tries b3 given up a pawn just to
create some counter play but Petrosyan
excels this so King captures on v3 we
have worked to these six moving away
from the night and now patrols in place
at five and this is a well this is
deadly
uniquor tries rook to b6 check but
petrosal simply put the King back to a2
and in this position well única resigned
there is no move for him to play well
the queen is attacked he is threatening
to capture on d6 if this point is
captured he kept he captures an f5 then
simply nice to be seven the d7 check is
completely crushing and black has
nothing to play whether the King goes to
e7 or g7 well doesn't really matter that
Rose example simply play the Knight
captures and b6 and this will this will
pick up a whole rook and well being a
whole roof down única resigned so yeah
wonderful game and I think the Trojans
ideas of marching the King from do you
want to be 1 and then a 2 although it's
a defensive idea it's well it's also an
attacking idea and this game I think can
rival any attacking game with its ideas
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed this especially the Kingdom
March and I I would like to thank you
all who make some contributions to my
channel especially I mean everyone it's
a wonderful gesture and I really
appreciate it so thank you Pierre thanks
you look cute as the board Thank You
grammatical Thank You Christopher
Ballinger and thank you for smarten it's
really appreciated and unlike for the
movie 300
well you're the entire Greece will not
know your names but surely Charles my
subscribers will so thank you guys so as
you
you can check to my previous videos here
and yeah I hope you enjoyed this game
and I'll see you soon